what's the goal here is the goal to get
to a billion yeah the goal is to get to
10 billion the mission is to just make
real business knowledge available for
everyone everything I do online that's
why I make the books so I make the
courses that's why we do the YouTube
stuff that's why we make the shorts or
we do podcasts that's why we do all of
it it's just to make real business
education available every but I have to
answer the question why should I listen
to you I want to be unassailable in that
perspective a and then B I do believe
that I'll gain more perspective as
things grow so it's more than I'm just
curious my goal is to just document the
path that we learn along the way you
know when I die hopefully there'll just
be a whole bunch of people who are
younger than me who make way more money
than I do at my age because they were
able to just shortcut a lot and I have
had many mentors in many coaching
programs in many courses I differ from
the vast majority of the talking heads
in the business space I to my knowledge
I'm the only one who came up through
that world like you look at Andy for
sale you look at my life you look at
Gary none of them came up through
learning stuff on YouTube going to
seminars going to coaching programs so
I'm a huge advocate for alternative
education